like my conventional deadlift my my best
pull from the floor is 7 35 and my best
pull from from three and like three or
four inch blocks is like 740 so
um and and that's basically because like
you know my weakest point in the
deadlift is basically where a three or
four inch block pull is starting so I'm
gonna have to go through that range of
motion with a pull from the floor I'm
gonna start at that part of the range of
motion for a three four inch block pull
so ultimately it doesn't make that much
of a difference if I do like a 600 block
pull like still below the knees I I'm I
am going to be able to pull more weight
but it's still not like a huge night and
day difference but then once I get above
my knee you know I can pull way way more
weight for Sumo on the other hand
and unfortunately I don't have video of
this you're just gonna have to trust me
uh my best deadlift from the floor Sumo
is
what is it it's either 705 or 725 I
don't do Sumo and meat so I don't pay
that close of attention but it's
somewhere in the low sevens
I've pulled 850 from a four inch block
uh or 855 from a four inch block Sumo so
we're talking an enormous difference and
so if I was someone whose arms just
happened to be four inches longer which
wouldn't be freaky outlier proportions
like that would that would if anything
give me more normal proportions I would
have a huge Advantage pulling Sumo
um and I essentially think that's
basically what's going on so if someone
has the hips for Sumo which I do and
they also have relatively long arms so
they can get in a starting position that
would be equivalent to a starting
position of a low block pull for someone
with shorter arms they're they're
cutting off a relatively large portion
of the range of motion that would
otherwise be the hardest part of the
range of motion and you just don't get
that same Dynamic with the conventional
deadlift and so as essentially what I'm
proposing is that for
the vast majority of individuals like 95
percent plus of people you don't have to
worry about that like that Dynamic isn't
in play uh you know Sumo will feel
better for some people conventional will
feel better for some people uh I think
largely just based on hip structure but
I think if you are one of the people who
has hips that are well suited to Sumo
and who also has kind of outlier body
proportions to allow allow your setup
from the floor to be comparable to a low
block pull setup for another person I do
think that that that for for that small
minority of lifters can net them a
pretty big advantage in the Sumo
deadlift and so
you know then that begs the question the
framing device for this segment is Sumo
cheating and I would say no absolutely
not uh I mean ultimately the point so
one you know you can just look at the
rules like in powerlifting the Sumo
allowed yes okay cool it's not cheating
uh and then two on average does it seem
to be way way easier than conventional
for most people no not really uh but
then it's like okay for a small minority
of people it does seem to give a pretty
big Advantage where if those same people
with really great body proportions for
conventional that or just great body
proportions for dead lifting in general
like if you have those proportions it's
going to help you for both Sumo and
conventional but it might help a little
bit more for Sumo than it does for
conventional
and so then that begs the question like
okay well is is it cheating or in some
way unfair that they get a bigger Boost
from sumo uh than than they would
conventional uh due to their outlier
body proportions and like
I think that just kind of depends on
your conception of fairness
um like I I fundamentally think it's
fine like those people have access to an
advantage that most people don't have
access to but ultimately that's just the
name of the game in Elite Sports like uh
every every sport on the planet at a
high level is basically just like hey
everyone's playing by the same rules uh
and who has the physiology that allows
them to best take advantage of those
rules and you know for for the for the
very very freaky Sumo deadlifters out
there you know I I think they just hit
the lottery and I think it is what it is
and that's fine and it's that's not just
like a weird Quirk of sumo being allowed
in powerlifting that's like how it works
for everything so you know like uh uh
NBA playoffs are going on right now and
you look at giannis's Absolute Wizardry
around around the rim like he's so tall
his arms are so long he's so [ __ ]
quick he's so explosive and he has an
insane touch around the back basket and
so you know scores a ton of points in
the paint with crazy efficiency and he
can penetrate into the paint way better
than most people because he can take
such long strides change direction so
well and he's so quick
that gives him a huge tangible Advantage
compared to virtually everyone he plays
against but no one would say that's
cheating it's just like oh well Giannis
won the genetic lottery for basketball
and uh yeah I think Kristoff Weir biki
won the genetic lottery for deadlifting
uh and that's fine
um so yeah I I think I think that there
are individuals who do get a huge boost
in performance from having access to
Sumo
that other people aren't like other
people aren't going to have access to
that Advantage just because they they
don't have the build for it
um but I fundamentally think that's fine
and I don't think that on average Sumo
gives the sort of advantage that would
lead one to classify it as cheating